big news morgans is a former member of
the roger pirates in other words a
member of the most powerful and
influential pirate crew in history
someone who fought side by side with the
likes of shanks rayleigh and roger
himself reaching the last island of the
grand line and just like shanks croakus
or rayleigh he has worked hard behind
the scenes to make rogers last welcome
true and has helped luffy to get where
he is today using his influence on the
world government and his monopoly on
information in the one piece worlds this
sounds of course absolutely preposterous
and i thought the exact same thing when
i first stumbled across this idea on my
subreddit wild anime theories however as
the reddit user legendary points out
correctly there is actually surprisingly
much evidence pointing in exactly that
direction and when you follow the
breadcrumbs that odel sensei left us it
only leaves us with one possible
conclusion big news morgan is very
likely a roger pirate to be more precise
he's one of these men right here i'll
tell you why in just a second also if
you haven't yet make sure to subscribe
it's actually free big news morgan is
not just anyone but one of the most
influential and powerful people in the
world and we really have no idea what he
actually looks like after all hola
sensei has confirmed that morgan's isn't
some type of intelligent animal like for
example a member of the mink's tribe but
a human that has eaten the bird bird
zone fruit model albatross in other
words similar to chopper morrigan is
constantly in his hybrid form so he
could be someone we've seen in the story
before without us ever realizing it
here's what we know so far about big
news morgan he's the president of the
world economy newspaper in other words
he's the one who prints the newspapers
that are being distributed across the
world by the infamous new school that's
the name of these birds that distribute
the news across the one piece worlds
while morgan's and his team look and
feel very quirky you shouldn't let
yourself be fooled here he is incredibly
powerful this world is fully controlled
by a global world government that not
only rewrites history to fit its own
purposes but also goes extremely hard
against anyone trying to share truths
and news that could harm its power i
mean just ask the scholars of o'hara
controlling information and keeping the
citizens of the world badly informed has
probably been the government's most
powerful tool to stay in power for the
past 800 years and yet here we have this
man that runs the world's biggest
newspaper that makes morgan one of the
most dangerous and influential people on
the planet i'm really curious why the
government has allowed him to build such
a monopoly in the first place my
personal guess would be that morgan used
to play along very nicely with the
government and kind of help them spread
their propaganda i mean we've already
seen that the government tried to bribe
him and that they had an undercover
agent at his office and so it really
feels like it was only quite recently
that morrigans has gone so openly
against the gorosei another reason
however is that morgans is one of the
emperors of the underworld where the
governments countries and pirates
altogether trade weapons information and
really anything else that's shady and
imaginable away from the public eye not
only does he have the power to shape
global opinions about anything but he
can also blackmail others by sharing
sensitive information literally for many
years he was part of the system that
helped the yonko and the government
alike in controlling the news and
cementing their power and even though
his influence is mostly through
information he is also physically quite
strong having no problem whatsoever
dealing with the cyphapul agent that
threatened him or standing side by side
with some of the strongest people in the
story heck he knew exactly that stussy
was an undercover agent as well and what
she was capable of and yet he was not in
the slightest intimidated by her
presence it was really only at the end
of whole cake island that morgan started
doing his own thing here he revealed his
interest in the supernova and started
cheering for luffy in particular to
become the next pirate king now you
could of course argue that all of these
things could simply be the
characteristics of a cunning and tough
journalist who just wants to get money
and i guess excitement out of it for
himself however this is where things get
a little bit fishy first of all what we
mentioned earlier it's really strange
that he never leaves his hybrid form
this is clearly to protect his true
identity in some way or form the only
question is who could morgans be that
would be so problematic for his job it
must be someone who would get him into
trouble either with the government or
cost him his credibility with his
readers also this journalist who has a
secret identity should be pretty
familiar to you because it's basically
the superman trope now i don't think
that morgans is the lurking legend or
anything like that but i do think that
this is oda sensei's take on that
superman trope and his fruit itself is
also quite suspicious too morgan is an
albatross devil fruit user the albatross
is notorious for its long-distance
flying abilities and yet morgan here
allegedly can't fly we also do know for
a fact that morgan was the one who
reported on luffy's exploit on whole
cake island and who declared him as the
next emperor before he made his way to
wano in fact we can assume that it was
his newspaper that has been distributing
news about the straw hats exploits
throughout the story and as far as i
remember the straw hats have always been
portrayed in quite a positive light
presented as this powerful crew of
upcoming pirates that bring turmoil to
wherever they go and while it's still
unclear whether or not morgan's has any
influence on the bounties themselves he
still seems to be the one to print and
distribute all bouncy posters i mean he
clearly was the one who put the photo of
gear 5 luffy on the new wanted poster
and has also included the d in his name
and so all of that strongly hints at big
news morgan having a secret agenda and a
secret identity that's actually pretty
crazy when you think about it so crazy
in fact that not only did i change my
outfit but it also got me hungry enough
for a snack and as luffy and co have
just learned during the celebrations in
wano there is nothing better but the
food from a traditional japanese
festival luckily the good people over at
baksu have us covered for exactly that
because this month's snack box theme is
matsuri
nights just seeing these lanterns makes
me wanna go to one so badly as you
probably already know each of these
monthly snack boxes contain a wonderful
assortment of traditional japanese
snacks candies and tea pairings from
local manufacturers here in japan no
matter where you live you can order the
same real japanese experience to your
house this here for example is covered
in chocolate and mixed with green tea
grown in kyoto but honestly all of this
month's box looks super delicious if you
want to get your hands on one of these
as well you can use the link in the
description below and use my personal
code o'hara for 15
of your very first order however why do
i say with such certainty that he might
be a roger pirate in disguise in
particular well you better put your
seatbelt on for this one let's begin
with the matter of roger finding the one
piece and becoming pirate king in the
first place i mean since it's the
premise for the entire story i think
none of us has ever really stopped and
questioned how roger got so famous in
the first place because when you think
about it it's kind of fishy too roger
was the first person in 800 years to
reach the last islands there he found
the one piece and named the island laugh
tale based on joyboy's story that he
read there however why would anyone
believe him who confirmed with certainty
that this actually happened and that
roger didn't just make it up in other
words someone had to actually tell the
press that this happened because roger
clearly wasn't the one who told the
world and if he did nobody would have
believed him we also saw that he was
reading the epithet pirate king in the
newspaper himself and found it amusing
so clearly it wasn't his idea and the
easiest explanation here is that the
news about roger were spread by someone
who was actually there in other words a
journalist who accompanied roger on his
trip either because roger was nice
enough to let him or because roger
himself just wanted to make a bit of a
name for himself and i do believe that
this person was morgan the man who
became famous for breaking the story and
naming roger pirates king this would
also explain morgan's crazy obsession
with luffy and the race for the next
pirate king perfectly as well as you
know roger was waiting for the return of
joyboy and in anticipation of his death
he did everything in his power to ease
the way for his return he fathered at
least one child with ace that he hoped
would become joy boy later he then
tasked his men with carrying on his will
and prepared joyboy's arrival he sent
out shanks to find the right person and
get his hands on the nikanika fruit
chang's was to give that person the
fruit and entrust him with roger's hat
he then stationed crocus at the entrance
to the grand line to scout for the
person with the straw hat tell them
about the final island and teach them
how to navigate the first half of the
grand line he then stationed his right
hand man rayleigh at the halfway point
on sabah odi rayleigh in the very same
matter would also identify joyboy by its
hat train him and then help him cross
into the new world the second part of
the grand line and one possibility is
that his third in command scapa gabon is
now waiting on roadstar island to teach
joyboy about love tale and the final
journey there but i guess that's a story
for uh not the video in itself because
as you've figured out by now morgan
would fit this pattern perfectly he has
helped to spread luffy's legend he's the
one who declared him an emperor and who
believes that he will be the next pirate
king now we've heard many people believe
in luffy finding the one piece and
becoming pirate king before but morgan
at least as i remember is the only one
that has never met luffy in person and
still believes it why well because he
also recognized
straw hats and so morgan has made sure
to favor luffy in public perception and
ease his way how so you may ask now well
remember how rayleigh shanks and ko keep
up with luffy's developments we've seen
shanks more than once read about luffy
in the news for whatever reason it seems
to be his trusted source of information
about luffy i personally would assume
that you would also expect chance to
keep an eye on luffy in some other way
but he seems suspiciously content with
just a regular newspaper well if morgan
was his former crewmate part of the same
mission to help joyboy then of course
shanks would trust that information heck
morgan most likely would put it there
for members of the roger crew to see in
the first place in this context i also
want you to think about the aftermath of
the war at marineford luffy returns to
marine hq to literally send a message to
the rest of the crew to train for two
years and meet back at sabah odi strong
enough to make it to the world blah blah
but that wasn't actually luffy's idea
yeah you guessed it it was rayleigh's
rayleigh proposed to luffy to get a
picture taken at marine fort with the
message on his arm visible to the
cameras and it was rayleigh who
accompanied him there yes it was a real
ballsy stunt of luffy to come back but
there was absolutely no guarantee that
it would make the news or that they
would use that exact picture of luffy
with the message clearly visible what if
the government wanted to cover this up
as well avoiding the humiliation of
having luffy back there and having him
escape a second time however if morgan
the one curating the news here was an
ally of rayleigh then of course he could
ensure that the straw hats receive
luffy's message in other words rayleigh
and morgan could have staged the entire
thing as a massive media stunt luffy
rings the bell lays down flowers and
then takes his hat off to pay respect to
those who have fallen while the marines
charge in there in the background like
idiots the reporters really have no
chance but portray luffy as the noble
mysterious rookie who has come with
jinbe and silva's rayleigh and one of
the reporters literally says this is big
news morgan's catchphrase before we ever
get to even meet him and once again we
see the marines reacting to this news
breaking saying that the article already
has spread around the world and is too
late to stop so once again just like on
whole cake islands and on wano news
about luffy gets out that the government
wants to keep quiet and morgan being a
roger pirate also would explain one of
the biggest plot holes in the entire
story why the hell is luffy's full name
always displayed on his wanted posters
we do know that the gorosei wants to
keep the d initial a secret including
for luffy as we well learned after wano
yet luffy has been wanted as monkey d
luffy on every single bouncy poster so
far i mean the government wanted to hide
that the initial so hard they even
bothered to rename goldie roger into
gold roger they also surely wanted to
hide luffy being related to garth so if
the government would have had it say i
bet that luffy would have been just
luffy on the bounty posters just how
shanks is just shanks but then if you
have someone in the news accidentally
publishing the d initial however who
operates on his own terms and who wants
the d-clan out in the open that would
explain a lot morgan really is the
missing piece linking rayleigh and
shanks and the other members of the
roger pirates that are now working to
make luffy the next pirate king and the
reason that hola sensei hides his
appearance is because we've now met all
of roger's crew through odin's flashback
and age-wise it also fits pretty
smoothly because he was in his early 20s
during roger's journey to love tales so
who out of rogers men here could morgans
possibly be i have four candidates for
you first is this guy here peter moo
that's just because he has a very
similar body shape to morgan's and is
also wearing a feathered hat then there
is momora who also wears a hat that is
strangely shaped like a bird set there
is moon isaac jr who has this
beak-shaped nose and who might be based
on sir isaac newton who discovered
gravity you know opposed to flight maybe
and finally there is spencer who i
really just threw in here because he
looks pretty much like a male version of
nami and i just wanted to kind of
mention that because it's kind of odd
another idea that i've seen thrown
around is that morgan might have been
the thing inside the giant egg here that
was on board of the roger pirates ship
however that is a whole different beast
i personally think and if you really
want to know what it is you can't miss
out on that video
right here